the definitive guide to ransomware event
routing capabilities for ibm cloud
activity tracker and new pricing plans
for the ibm security and compliance
center all on this episode of ibm tech
now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
the ibm security x-force team just
continues to do rad stuff and the latest
bit of knowledge they're dropping on us
is the 2022 update to the definitive
guide to ransomware a comprehensive
report on how to educate yourself
prepare and deal with ransomware attacks
ransomware is an online attack
perpetrated by cyber criminals who
demand money to release their hold on
encrypted or stolen data
the x-force team has seen a rapid
increase in ransomware attacks over the
last three years
and the average duration of an
enterprise ransomware attack reduced by
94
this means that the average time to
complete an attack went from two plus
months in 2019 to just under four days
in 2021
in other words these cyber criminals are
getting fast
so ransomware attacks are becoming more
efficient and way more costly for the
victims
in the most extreme cases attackers
demand victimized companies pay as much
as 40 to 80 million dollars to have
their data released back to their
control
luckily for you the report provides an
insane amount of useful info on how to
educate yourself about ransomware and it
details the steps to follow in a
ransomware incident's life cycle which
are preparation detection and analysis
containment eradication and recovery and
post-incident activities
to get all the useful info and start
prepping yourself check out the report
which i've linked in the description of
this video
next up ibm cloud activity tracker is
expanding your ability to configure and
route activity event data to multiple
alternate locations in the service
audit events are critical data for
security operations and a key element
for meeting compliance requirements
control over the handling of these
events and where they are stored is
essential when building enterprise grade
solutions
the new event routing feature enables
you to consolidate activity tracker data
to the region of your primary operations
route to one or more locations improve
your data residency compliance stature
feed a data lake for analytics
and forward your activity event data to
ibm cloud object storage for financial
services compliance
to learn all about the capabilities of
the new feature
hit the link below
the final thing i want to touch on today
is the new pricing plans for the ibm
security and compliance center
the security and compliance center is
ibm cloud's answer for centralized
security and compliance posture
the team has completed the evaluation
period and received overwhelming
interest in the product's capabilities
so the next step is the introduction of
pricing plans
first you've got the trial plan to try
out the service you can enroll in a
trial period that allows you to access
the full capabilities of the service for
30 days
then you've got the standard plan with
the standard plan you are able to access
the full capabilities of the posture
management component without being
inhibited by a trial period
for this one you're charged per
evaluation
to learn more about the pricing plans
and what they mean for you check out the
blog link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now